it was my first time being threatened
with a lawsuit by a billionaire I was
shaking in my boots it was a really
scary experience but I feel like it's
like a rite of passage if you don't have
a source that threatens to sue you then
are you even doing the job correctly
[Music]
Andre Andre he's been on Forbes radar
basically since early 2018 our
colleagues at Forbes Russia they were
the ones who identified him as a
billionaire the source of his wealth is
technology and he went to the University
of Moscow and dropped out when he was 18
and moved to Spain so he's got this
unique Russian Western European
influence to him
[Music]
I was actually planning a vacation
earlier this year and I decided if I can
get Andre to meet with me in London then
I would plan my vacation around Europe
so we met at this restaurant called Hyde
I was in a private dining area on the
second floor
and I looked up and he was just walking
towards me and he had on his signature
white t-shirt he's got hundreds of white
t-shirts they're all Prada and he had on
a black bomber jacket black jeans and he
just kind of strolled in and walked
towards me like he owned the place and
it was at Hyde when he gave me a
business exclusive they were going to
commit a hundred million dollars to find
him the next big social app I thought
okay this is the exclusive that I need
to sort of anchor this story and make it
into a bigger piece but then he offered
to take a walk around London with me and
he offered to show me his favorite
restaurants and bakeries and tea shops
and I think in total our meeting was
about five hours so then I started on
the second stage of my reporting which
is reaching out to former employees
investors associates and that's really
when the real story started coming out
I had former employees who told me that
Andre was prone to making racist
comments that when he saw too many
blacks and browns faces on the apps that
had cheapened the brand another thing
that people had told me about the
company was you really need to look into
the corporate structure of that do the
way that it's structured it's basically
created to avoid taxes I had four former
employees that confirmed to me that
there was a video of an employee
receiving oral sex from a sex worker
that was circulating around the office
but then I found Jessica Powell's book
she wrote this book called the big
disruption she talks about how the book
was inspired by our time at Google but
also partly inspired by her time at a
start-up where the founder had
considered changing the app into an
anonymous sex club and even white
boarded it and had asked her whether it
was a good idea to give away dill
as companies swag and it was a founder
who also owned hundreds of white
t-shirts and when I read that line I
thought holy [ __ ] that's Andre
she was pretty hesitant to speak to me
but I could kind of tell that she wanted
to tell that story it's just that nobody
had asked her or nobody took her
seriously and so it took some time to
build her trust but eventually I got her
to speak to me and not just speak to me
she spoke to me on the record which was
huge for the story when people think
about Bumble they think about its CEO
Whitney will have heard what most people
don't realize is that Andre is the
majority owner of Bumble so to have all
of that and to have bumble leaning in so
hard to this feminism and anti massagin
ISM aspect to their brand it just all
seemed pretty hypocritical you have to
bend over backwards to give your source
as every opportunity to comment and this
was the type of story where I needed
Andre and the company to know everything
that was going in the story and yeah I
started asking him you know these
employees tell me that the London
headquarters is a toxic workplace
especially for women what's your
response to that and it just kind of
spiraled Andre emails pretty much
everyone that's above my pay grade at
Forbes basically he attacked the
integrity of the story and was doing
everything he could to stop the story
from publishing I want to say that you
know none of it scared me but I was
pretty scared and whenever they tried to
poke holes in my reporting method of my
story I immediately went to those areas
and I just kind of did a mental
calculation are they right this is a
type of story that you just need to
bulletproof you can't get anything wrong
so the story went live I get this DM
from a TechCrunch reporter hi angel we
just got a statement from Andre and
Whitney and they're claiming that there
are factual inaccuracies in your story
and that the company is working with you
on correcting those inaccuracies I
wanted to give you a chance to respond
and when I read that I freaked out I
think Andre and Whitney might have
realized that that aggressive approach
might not be the best strategy because
you had people on Twitter that I mean
one of my sources literally revealed her
identity on Twitter to say this story is
true this is who I am I actually went
through this so the next day Andre and
the company gives another statement to
Business Insider and their tone has
completely changed Andre is a much more
apologetic in the statement and they
talk about how the company had hired a
law firm to independently investigate
the claims and the story I remember when
I was in school it was one of my
professor said there's only two kinds of
journalism that matters you either
comfort the afflicted or you afflict the
comfortable the process of getting a
response from the company and everything
that happens after even though it was
probably one of the more stressful times
that I've gone through in journalism I
learned so much and the story that ended
up coming out I think it was really
beyond anybody's expectations
you